does razor wire
work does razor wire work for what this
is uh Joe Biden's National Security
adviser John Kirby who mostly spends his
time wearing suits that fit in a very
very strange way seems like he has a
small body big suit syndrome uh here he
is explaining that barbed wire doesn't
work uh they put barbed wire everywhere
like chicken coups and jails and borders
and pretty much anywhere you wouldn't
want somebody but uh he knows that it
doesn't actually
work does razor wire
work does razor wire work for what does
it work for the border patrol to allow
them to have the access they need to be
able to uh to better process people that
are uh trying to get across the border I
don't think so and that's why we asked
for it to be removed what are you
talking about the the barbed wire the
razor wire it was put there so that
these people can't come in but what he's
saying is oh it doesn't work if you want
to let everybody and if you want to
process these people well then the
barbed wire is a problem now if you want
evidence that barbed wire wire works if
you're a serious nation and you want to
keep people out of your country uh
here's a little barbed wire over at the
Egypt Gaza border because Egypt for some
strange reason they don't want all their
Palestinian Brothers uh wandering into
Sinai well some better tell the
Egyptians that that doesn't work that
wall with all that wire think about all
of the money they've wasted on that wire
to keep Palestinians out of Egypt very
very
bizarre